[Music]
there's a big rivalry between georgia
and the state of florida apparently yeah
yeah but they do have one thing in
common both states are known for their
fruit georgia is famous for its peaches
florida is famous for its oranges
but which state fruit is superior
i thought we'd find out once and for all
with a fight to the death fruit battle
right here on television
that's right
here representing your home state the
ultimate southern treat the georgia
peach
the peach
the peach stands almost seven feet tall
and weighs a perfect 226 pounds it's
filled with over 45 gallons of delicious
georgia grown peach nectar and here
representing your neighbor to the south
the florida orange
[Music]
[Applause]
you're booing in orange
the orange stands at just over four feet
tall weighs a poultry 62 pounds it's
filled with high levels of citric acid
that can destroy your teeth and stomach
lining let the fight to the death fruit
battle begin
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
georgia reigns supreme